i was on twitter this morning and i do
my little morning scroll before i get
out of bed and i did not see
one uh beheading video i was absolutely
shocked nothing new in the beheading
world
but yeah a lot of bad isis stuff is
happening and
a egyptian social media activist her
name is aaliyah
magda almadi she's 23 years old
she posted a rather interesting image on
facebook
let's take a look at the image
okay so that is her facing us and she
has is
obviously written on her chest she is
menstruating
on the isis flag there and then that is
another girl and she's got the other is
so isis
and she's pooping on the isis flag
uh she is getting a lot of [ __ ] no pun
intended
uh uh on facebook for this a lot of
people are very upset with her
this is a major bold statement by by a
true activist she doesn't want these
people
taking over her country her part of the
world i commend her for it
um but she's really putting herself out
there
absolutely um so i guess i don't want to
be too glib about this but i will just
start with this like how long is this
girl going to live because in this part
of the world you do something against
the power
i don't know how many you know we've
done beheading videos for the last month
like how long before they get her right
my question is uh was it spontaneous are
you just hanging out you're on your
period
friend really needs to use the restroom
you happen to have
a flag there you know what i mean that
is all right we're going
to start i like it that's good no i mean
i think it's
you know i i applaud her because that's
how you know
i feel like the ideology of isis really
should
be treated like the you know the crap
that it is you know
yeah um but yeah i worry for her where's
she based again is she she's in egypt
supposedly i'm not exactly sure where
she is right now and i'm sure she's
doing some sort of hiding
situation but she is in egypt at least
last we heard
wow yeah um bravo yeah so does this work
kind of in two ways because
not only is she making a statement about
isis but she's also making a statement
for women and it's really not going that
great for women in the middle east
either right so this is pretty good
just on the woman front i think it's
pretty ballsy because she's doing it
without a mask on i mean those guys are
beheading with a cover over their face
and she's not doing that so
right away to me it takes a tremendous
amount of balls and more balls than what
they have
yeah in my opinion um when we talk about
this do you think we
we strengthen her side or do you think
we strengthen the other side because
for you know on one hand it's we bring
attention to it yeah and on the other
hand it's like well then they go ah see
the western media is
showing this girl [ __ ] on us because
they hate us yeah everything that i've
seen
from isis or the islamic state whatever
they're being referred to as now i mean
they're
to me they're they're almost worse than
nazis they're not friends of women
they're terrible terrible people
uh not friends of women to say yeah yeah
just put it mildly the the religious
police i
saw i saw them patrolling raqqa that's
the name of the town that they've taken
over now in northern syria right and
they're just like
i mean what a what a cancer
on on humanity they are it's just you
know absurd